well George is the closest thing I have
to a younger brother so you can imagine
the affection and the pride I have in in
him but there were so many I'm about
three or four or five years older than
the wonderful generation that did so
much so I'm I'm very proud of them and
and and the fact that this is the foul
burg award is the significance is not
lost on me because this is a ward for
producing this is not about my own
writing in my own filmmaking but this is
this is about the talent that I came to
really value and it's more about
American Graffiti and the black stallion
and Koyaanisqatsi and I could go on
about Napoleon performed in the Radio
City Music Hall with a live orchestra
that happened because I had always heard
from my father that in the days when he
was a boy
when he went to the movies to see Don
Juan or the FIFA Baghdad that there was
a Symphony Orchestra and I said see I'd
love to see that and the way to see it
was to take the Napoleon restoration and
get a full-out Symphony Orchestra and
perform it and it was a wonderful hit it
was riveting and I'm so proud of the
fact that that tradition of once again
combining live music with the great
silent films or with any film has become
really something that we can see I I
don't have any words prepared in fact
I'm shooting a picture and last night
we're shooting nights so so I went to
bed around 4:00 in the morning last
night and I said well I'll just get up
and thank everyone for this honor right
I remember seeing the Thalberg award
given and thought wow that's that's
fantastic and in a way although I still
consider myself a relatively young
person I'm one of the few people you'll
meet today who actually worked for Jack
Warner and had him say no fog on the
lake or or Sam Goldwyn
when he said to me you know your films I
like your films for the spontaneity
exactly and so I had the pleasure of RIT
I do a great Samuel golden as does
Warren he said to me Sammy will go and
said to me so what are you doing you're
a golden scholar you're so great they
said well I'm I want a direct little
bike you should be like that
right are you all right I know like
right right
so a year later I made a film and I got
a letter mr. Golder would like to see
you oh you're a golden scholar this is
really the way he talked by the way I'm
not your Goldwyn Scalia so what are you
doing I said well I'm thinking of
writing a new film hiding your doctor
now it is a nothing direct electorate so
you know out of zuker Darryl zanuck who
incidentally as as was said was the the
first winner of the FAL Berg one I think
he wanted more than once as a matter of
fact so I I have a great love of the the
original Hollywood tradition certainly
going back to the silence which was some
of the most beautiful movies ever made
Mar now by the way had said himself he
said the coming of sound to movies was
inevitable but it came too soon came too
soon which there is some truth in those
were beautiful films I you know I'm I'm
so proud of my family my wife of 48
years like Eleanor who's here
my fabulous children I made a very wise
decision when I was a young guy I said
to my wife if I ever go away for more
than two weeks I want to take the kids
out of school imagine that today take
the kids out of school I'm taking them
with me and I we always did and as a
result we had our family together
through all of those adventures in the
Philippines and what-have-you so and
then of course the other children the
Schwartzman family and of course in I
can't say the cage family but we're very
proud of Nicholas as you can imagine so
I I could tell you lots of stories but I
haven't prepared any any notes or
anything other to thank you from the
bottom of my heart and and and my my
admiration for the tradition of Irving
Thalberg and of course of the fantastic
producers who have who ever have wanted
and not the least of it is Dino you know
for the lost to lose they know hey you
know Francis
I don't do Dino so well I think Warren
does be me any rate I thank you from the
bottom of my heart I thank my family I
thank my friends so many of my friends
are here tonight and people I've worked
with my my colleagues and the people
I've whose films I've admired thank you
so much thank you
you
you